crab feast you know what it's all about
this is the crab feast I'm yelling [ __ ]
that you ain't gotta ask me cuz you
could trust that every Tuesday you
already know though Orion Zack the
soccer star JUCO above ground crew goes
better than most Jay Larson
self-diagnosed go download this week
last week here we go again for the crab
feast
can you feel
welcome back to the crab feast y'all
doesn't Tuesday on the trapeze for that
ass I was worried about you over there
for a second if you were imagine being
12 years old going back and your teacher
being like what are you gonna do when
you're when you're old you're like I'm
gonna have like a a radio show that you
know an internet radio show like how
would you open it mommy my buddy you're
gonna try to touch each others were to
accidentally do that and then be stuck
but I mean how stupid are we for the
stupidest it's so stupid oh it's good to
be here jail are good to be here with
you good to be here with everyone out
there and future nation you're like my
proud little children I'm so proud of
you guys and honestly I love being a
part of each nation including as a fan
and as a part of the podcast what we're
glad to have you thank you sir tomorrow
night I'll be at common juice in LA and
then coming up down the road may 21st
i'll be in nashville at zanies with the
LOL TBD show with Nate bargatze Rory
Scovel and Nick Thune and then coming up
right around the corner from the first
week in June bridgetown comedy festival
very excited crappy feedback that be a
third year in a row they're doing a live
podcast guests will be announced and
time and date will be announced but we
will be there and we're excited if
you're in the region it's a it's an
awesome awesome comedy fest it's
absolutely one of the best comedy
festivals in the country no doubt about
love to see you there sickle Ryan
Sickler on Twitter and Instagram Ryan
Sickler official on facebook Ryan
Sickler dot-com I want to thank everyone
we want to thank everyone who came out
to the live podcast the Hollywood improv
thank you for the support it's a monthly
thing we're doing we love seeing you out
there thanks for coming out and fill in
the room up and laughing and having a
good time with us also on april fifth we
have a crappy stand-up show at The
Comedy Store 8 p.m. and tickets for all
these shows are on Ryan Sickler calm and
the crab feast calm where you can
support us by buying your merch and
wearing it to shows like you do the
Amazon link is a huge huge help and
thank you for all of you who do that
the new premium app with Pete Holmes and
Baron Vaughn live from Rydell a is
kicking ass thank you all for your
support on that as well it is available
on iTunes and Apple music excuse me
available on Google Play if you're an
Android user also on the Amazon music
store and if you just want the mp3 you
can load it so you can load it on your
device the way you like you can get a
direct download at gum Road calm / the
crab feast and links to all the premium
apps or on the crab feast calm they're
very easy to find and thank you for the
love and the support on the facebook fan
page and as always on the itunes page
yeah anyway you help out we appreciate
it and we appreciate you we also
appreciate this week's sponsor you know
it's just great you know Ryan I are very
selective about who we get sponsorships
with and these guys have been amazing
and everyone has been talking about it
that's just from what we've been putting
out there Omaha Steaks we talk about it
because we got them and we eat them and
we love it and then but also so many of
you out there and no of them and you've
had him and you know what deal you're
getting you know you're getting a deal
when you hear this and you see what you
get your yeah it's ridiculous as it has
they you know they're 3 that they're
able to do is is amazing high-quality
one-of-a-kind flavor everything from
seafood veggies bison I mean anything
whatever your diet is Omaha Steaks can
give it to you our this is an insane
deal what they're offering right now is
seventy-six percent off this package a
filet mignon top sirloin boneless pork
chops chicken fried steaks meatballs
jumbo franks potatoes are grotton's from
scratch caramel apple tartlets which are
the lt's jam i think i've said it before
and premium ground beef burgers all this
stuff you can break up in the freezer
pull it out the night before and boom
it's red eagle the next day for 4999 you
get all of this which equates to about
20 meals for 50 bucks that's just you
don't get that anywhere that's that's a
ridiculous deal right now if you go to
Omaha Steaks calm typing crab feast in
the search bar up top and the search bar
press return to get this great deal Oh
mistakes calm enter crab feast in the
search bar get this great deal 49 99
seventy-six percent off
I we're proud of it very cool so glad
that I'm on board also glad to have
seatgeek back if you've ever been
frustrated trying to buy tickets online
because most likes make it complicated
they try to sneak in these huge fees to
check out seatgeek doesn't pull any of
that stuff that's why you not need to
try seatgeek they've made it even easier
than ever to buy and sell supports and
concert tickets see geeks the only place
ever go to look for tickets to a game or
concert I have the seat geek app on my
phone and I just use it the other day
actually to look at the Orioles Dodger
tickets they're coming out again for
like the second time in almost 20 years
and I talked to Jay Larson over here
about taking our kids out little crab
feast night take our son and daughter
out to watch the Dodgers and the Orioles
play out there in Dodger Stadium
seatgeek has taken all the work and
hassle out of shopping for tickets they
pull all the tickets available on other
sites into one place so you save time
and never miss a deal you can even set
alerts for upcoming events and seek ich
will let you know if ticket prices fall
even better every ticket on seatgeek is
ranked based on value so you can
immediately find under priced seats and
before you buy you can use C geeks
detailed maps to see the view from your
seat that's I always look for those
interactive maps because you can
actually see what you're really seeing
best of all see geek is always honest
and upfront about the price unlike
stubhub they show you the full ticket
price from start to finish and never try
to check trick you with huge fees on the
checkout page our listeners get a
twenty-dollar rebate off their first
seatgeek purchase to get your $20 rebate
on tickets download the free seatgeek
app go to the Settings tab and click add
a promo code and enter promo code crab
see geek will send you twenty dollars
after you've made your first ticket
purchase download the free seat gig app
and enter promo code crab today uh this
is a pretty special episode weary couple
reasons one sub 200th episode very
excited to have done 200 episodes on
that that's it's almost four years play
it doesn't even clued the live so this
is 200 episodes which is yeah it's fair
that Sam I'll stone haven't few of us I
mean who I've enjoyed my time with you
Jason Larson and my time with all of you
I I have definitely enjoyed my time with
future nation
I do that some ups and downs with me a
new cycle we get through it we get
throat like a brother to me son uh and
it's also special episode because of our
guest yeah you I like I think I think
you know a little more about it than I
do you talk to them a little more I mean
our guest today has been diagnosed with
mesothelioma and he's been given at this
initial diagnosis was given a year to
live and hopefully those things are
changing along with medicine he's
undergoing treatment as well as looking
into any and everything he can do to
extend that and he's out there getting
ready for a special that he's doing and
we thought it would be a special
opportunity to have him come on get to
know a little bit about him what he's
going through and tell some stories and
share some stories with us so we're very
excited to have him here we're excited
to have him here excited he got it he
got it you know I mean that way we got
him on here she's [ __ ] no I'm kidding
he knows it too we're excited please
welcome to the crab feast the first time
mr. Quincy Jones all right it feels
great to be here it's so good to have
you here Quincy Jones it's about time it
is about time huh you know I remember
remember that show you were doing that
was like a storefront where the hell was
that guess I'll report you Echo Park eat
the echoes under sunset no wasn't echoes
on a sunset wasn't that now remember
there's like a little storefront that
some kid owned and he turn it into like
he lived there and all gay they call
that Dangerfield's three yeah exactly
they did sign out all right like a
sandwich board on the side I a dangerous
three that's right around the corner
from where I live now actually mmhmm
yeah that's when I let that's what I
always associate you with I would you
know [ __ ] you let me know because
remember being there my shitty thing to
be associated well that's impressive did
he remember meeting you like that I mean
I'm dumb just thinking no I'm I'm
distinctive you know where i met i
remember meeting you the first time was
we were at shittiest at the grammy's
backstage with jeffrey oz without it
down to Jones fly up I weren't
she I don't remember that I'm out of
that side thank you so much for being
here this is uh this is a special this
is a special time I guess and won't you
tell everybody where they can find you
on social media just plug Quincy Jones
away yo el l QJ 206 on Twitter and the
gram and I don't have snapchat does
someone else have Quincy Jones yeah just
doing my square you left the right even
biting for a minute now but I let it
slide I'm a nice too I'm hot right now
so oh you're on fire you're on fire
right now can you put that out knock it
I can't even say not straight face
that's how hot I am I was cheesing as I
Sam hope I know uh find me on ll q Jay
206 in the gram and twitter and facebook
com back / q Jones a comedian love it
yeah you should have been a rapper I
used to rap did you I mean dude who says
the gram yeah I heard house tonight now
want to like knock it but I'm like other
people go I GSC that nice all about the
grand are in stock girl taking sultry
pics for the gram like that it's easy
right yeah then check me on the gram
yeah I don't yeah that's it I don't owe
you guys are snapchat no no I don't know
fine you guys on right now I'm on it I'm
doing the headline cuz we're grown me
that's right yeah we're grown man we
have family wait when were you rapping
when ya see the years of phase of my
life the chapters the major said I used
to do spoken word poetry yeah he did
right work where I did that um and then
uh you know what you know we're much
hustled hooped play play ball okay these
are things like a debug GT yeah would
you think we talk about a lot Mike and I
want to know how exciting Senate is
hoping this is what's amazing is you
talk to people my Tiffin it's as soon as
you start talking he's like I've shot 62
people haha justifiable played overseas
in Europe we are hoops like I mean I
went to school like Seattle like is a
hotbed of oops ours Brandon Roy Nate
Robinson all these people dude [ __ ] date
he's love celtic for a while
was it yeah Mandy kidding me Neil
Robinson he was our bike rack Isiah
Thomas for the Celtics right now he's
from see it down to is he yeah I'm lot
of runoff Terrence Ross for Houston
Rockets like we put out ball players and
what why don't why don't we do this real
quick why don't you promote uh what's
going on right now and then we're going
to go through those chapters okay of
your life right now uh I have a go fund
me that you could donate to a call Kwame
don't play that I'm fighting
mesothelioma I've stage for peritoneal
mesothelioma the really rare form of
cancer like a really really stage fours
pretty Demi that's a big stage that's a
big stage they go to just that's it
that's it that's it you sure like I if I
was in dr. obviously shows on a 505
where's the visiting would they take it
sounds how did you get it I don't know
that's why I hired lawyers to try and
figure out like investigate all the
addresses when I'm and everything what
do you wait what do you mean well I'll
tell you what I mean I don't want it to
say this but I'm going to say this a
really good friend of Mines dad passed
from how do you say mesothelioma a
mesothelioma and read the way he got it
was his father worked in asbestos and
when he would come home and sit on the
furniture and stuff microscopic bits
over the years get on and the kids are
play and they breathe it in and then it
takes years but it eventually got you
and catches up with you that's why I
didn't know did if you did anyone in
your family work around asbestos or my
pops wasn't around by ask my mom what
you know just now just now like within
the past week I was like what did what
did the old man do he actually worked at
Boeing you know i'm saying so maybe and
she's like your mattress is made out of
his best that might have been some laid
on list for six years you had asbestos
hook that's where you're an amazing yeah
that was the best best bestest no wait a
minute it was a type of cancer that you
cuz i always think of cancer is
something that like you just it just
turns up in your body unless you got
like sun cancer or you know something
like radiation what kids
people get some too much Sun tea skin
cancer I wouldn't know I wouldn't know
yeah I got melanin I wouldn't know where
skin get but no I made me do it it takes
20 to 50 years for it to pop up that's
the latency period 2250 and you're how
old now I'm 31 how did you find out that
like my belly was getting like full like
in December 30th of 2014 my belly was
full like it felt like I was like three
months pregnant was rock hard too and so
I was like damn like with the [ __ ] i
went to the ER I've been doing in the ab
workouts right you know I'm saying I'm
not pregnant how does this work so uh
went to the ER and they were like yo you
got ascites and I was like where's that
come from you're like serosa deliver a
kidney failure I was like damn I gotta
stop drinking and they're like well no
you don't the both of those are fine I
was like so I can keep drinking like a
good that's like cuz I'm drunk right
like the third like that for real I was
like yo I really did like you don't
think you have a problem sitter like cut
it cold turkey ya like like I've been
doing this asbestos cocktail oh so wait
date that's what they told you that's
they told you had at first 90 days we
can say that's what a sexy I didn't find
out for the first six months of 2015 I
just kept getting my belly train
arrogant like four to seven liters off
each time cheese just kidding Dre and
they were keep the holidays yes in the
kidney tests and delivered her like
still good they like would numb it would
like some some like some numbing thing
yeah and then they would like make a
little slit and then they were like
stick a catheter in there and then like
drain it in tomorrow and yet to do that
monthly once sometimes even two times a
month yeah like but like every time the
fluid kept coming back so June fifteenth
we did a biopsy they're finally they're
like yo doc we can't keep doing this
right we got taking next to it I'm gonna
be honest with you I'm the medical
expert but if my doctor was saying yo
dawg I do look for I've like man come on
be professional
man they were straight up in the hood
they keep a rude dr. hood doctor you
just pictured a little but little black
and you got cut out of your doctor
darling I see him a cornrows yo dawg I'm
not shy listen fam I don't know how to
tell you this looking good baby she's
not looking good for you doc we gotta
tighten up man yeah quit drinking like
everything no not everything every
divers you gotta indulge a little bit
right come on okay so obviously they
finally say look we can't do that keep
draining your stomach monthly here
sometimes multiple times a month right
and they do a biopsy they do a biopsy
and then like I go on tour it was june
15 that was a Monday I get out the
hospital Wednesday I mean but keep in
mind like they [ __ ] every time I went
underneath the needle they [ __ ] up
like a gravely like they said they were
gonna just here's what they said for the
Bobbsey don't like we're gonna make
three small incision your stomach puff
you up with some air take a sample your
stomach lining close you up stitch up
right sounds good here to get some
answers do that so I sign up you know I
boom give up everything ok cool I wake
up in excruciating pain oh I was like yo
what the [ __ ] happened they're like oh
we took out your appendix what what they
took out my appendix and like a wallet
tissue they showed me like this big in
like a low vile and now just like dark
can you guys do that legal yeah my
connect why am I in a bathtub of ice why
am I about that doctor was like I
remember waking up I was like oh hang on
this I'm in pain I'm like what did what
happened and my girl at the time was
like oh yeah they took out your appendix
I was like the [ __ ] do you mean they
took out my I didn't sign up for that
like we could sue but not in the
paperwork that you sided says we could
do whatever [ __ ] we want you can like we
took a kidney to yay pretty much so that
so then I went and toured at East Coast
I went to went to your city went to
being tonight and I started a tour I
took a red-eye Saturday night from here
got there sunday morning where was the
show
uh the studio did the comedy stand did
it like all over there and did at the
Paragon yeah it's right there and I
haven't done it but right there near
Romany yeah Harvard get right around the
corner so I did there I was doing tour
and my boy Towanda uh he was you showing
me though I was staying with but monday
morn love right now Towanda get here to
Wanda for a second thing's gonna buster
yeah I can't believe it to heat you get
back to sign for a second I thought I
was like Nick Oh Mandy I'm glad together
huh we tried eating called but uh we yes
and then I did that [ __ ] and I went to
the ER there and they tried to drain my
stomach right and then they like it came
out like red like bloody fluid and I was
like you guys messed up I've been doing
this now for six months and like I know
what the fluid supposed to look like you
guys ruptured something and so they're
like you're right and they like pulled
out you know saying and it did you know
this solution they took out a liver they
took a what day today so they took a
long long story short i go to i go to
boston new york and jersey and I go to
ers and each of those she and then in
Jersey I'm July third if I get the
results back from the biopsy in June
fifteenth and they're like yo it's
cancer I was like what like what type of
cans like parrots and I was like I never
worked in a breaks I never did manual
labor what are you talking about too
late yeah I was like so what'd I do now
they're like you go home mmm I was like
okay so i went home on the fourth of
July no and I told him I needed a day
let me chill for day I get out your life
order like take as much time as you want
i was like no you guys charge so i'm
gonna be okay forget beds not free so i
flew out July fifth I came back home and
that's when I realized I [ __ ] up to
healthcare system is I like Google what
a cancer doctors call it was called it
on colleges and I called one is like yo
I need to see you I got cancer they told
you to go home yeah and so I was like I
figure I gotta call somebody yeah yeah
so I called them up and they're lighting
ladies like do you have an HMO or PPO i
was i got médicale you're like no sir do
you have an HMO or PPO I was like lady
I've never heard these words in my life
I don't know what you're saying she's a
google hmm
imagine preferred becomes like yeah I
got the cheap one whatever there's one
that likes as I can't go to all of them
so yeah okay you gotta medica okay so
what you need to do is go to a doctor to
get him get over girl yeah so even
though I knew I had cancer I doubt
another doctor to hear i had cancer to
go get our then i go to the doctor
they're like hey we got the results as
cancers like I know it's cancer what do
we do they're like first of all that
could be a lot of fun though because you
already know it so he's gonna come in
and be like listen I not tell you like
cancer and he's like you know cuz you
know they probably kind of like as much
as they don't wanna have to tell you
they've Kansas it's probably a little
power trip with it like what else do
right now is got cancer well what I
thought his i would get start getting
treatment or seeing on college is then
right yeah so they're like you know it's
about a six-week wait to see an
oncologist and it always amazes me I had
sounds like an off calls no it's always
amazing to me a friend two friends of
ours father's right now I have cancer
and that was like yeah you go home and
your surgeries in five weeks it's like
five more weeks this thing gets that you
know have its way with me before I even
get in there to attack it baby expect
she I was like nah dawg like I can't
just chill you can't do anxiety a lot
alike you got cancer but sit tight for
six weeks and we'll see you when we get
a chance it's like not so I went to the
ER I was like you i walked in i was like
yo I got ascites I have cancer and I
haven't had treatment and I need to get
treatment so then they took they
admitted me and I was there in the
hospital for 45 days last year whole oh
[ __ ] yet include those ER stops on the
East Coast nah not for whole new leg of
the tour ossible toys yo it's real tars
we should have been caught but yeah man
I was in LA County I had a tooth
infection they took it out three days
later it's got cancer like yeah I won't
catch insects ya know but for 45 days
they are administering medicine whatever
it a chemo what are they doing to God re
no no no you're thinking sensibly this
is LA County
I listen I've had quite the [ __ ] year
with these los angeles hospital duh
that's for the birth of my daughter
everything else is sucked I have no
problem saying that they waited so long
the cancer spread to my lung no way dead
dead serious what are they today they're
just housing you for 45 days basically
they were just pumping me full of that
allotted ah which is great it's a great
payment but it ended constipating you
don't shift for weeks te says I so like
you're riding high you're riding high
every three hours again like four
milligrams in your [ __ ] vein here
just like sleeping coming to whatever I
didn't get Tremont I was I went in the
hospital like July eighth cutting in my
first dose of treatment a chemo till
august eighth and the only reason you
went in July eighth is because you
walked into an emergency room and said I
have this I got in the treatment not but
if you followed the system it have been
what six more weeks before even got to
the first point I probably made it meant
to be something i was down 145 when I
went yeah damn I'm telling me all's I
need to do is get from cancer and I can
drop down to 1 190 I got loot your Lee's
wife and kids too yeah or Jia Li doesn't
well that means are off well do what a
journey yeah i mean we're speaking yes I
can kill her can I talk I just want to
know like so where was it it was in your
stomach isn't much and it spread up to
your lungs we'll see the thing about my
cancer is not a traditional form it
doesn't lump up like a clump of cancer
cells it's in the lining so just blocks
vessels mm-hmm and the fluid has to go
somewhere so a mine it backed up in the
belly mesothelioma there's like second
umbrella so there's like mesothelioma
and then there's three types the stomach
the heart the lung the hearts of most
rare it has obviously probably the most
deadly because if it blocked the bus oh
yeah you're done the lungs are most
common you know it's also where it
blocks and you get fitted you're
breathing it in right and in the stomach
lining for me it was just I don't know
they just got there so so at this point
you also can't trace it back to
something in your life of where you got
cuz you obviously you've got this as a
cancer you get from
thing but like you were saying Jake okay
nerd lives inside you and beyond oh yeah
that's true yeah I never even knew that
could happen you know I mean and I'll
only I see the commercials all the time
so the only reason I know specifically
what what this is because my a good
friend of Mines father had it yeah
that's why it's a crazy one because like
one like dude may I wish I could go into
detail about how [ __ ] up that for
those 45 days were like it was really
[ __ ] up but to the point where like
first of all it's like a it's a training
school for doctors right so you get the
meadows you get the medical school
student yeah right these [ __ ]
are just eager right they have no
bedside manner they have no common sense
like do woke me up to tell me that the
cancer spread like [ __ ] you not just
happening on the leg tap tapping the
foot no bad side etiquette that was that
was a bedside manner dude dude told me
we here's think they did a surgery uh
because the fluid backed up right and it
so it was so much fluid it moves the
things wrap moves every like the body
parts around mhm so it moved everything
is pressing up against my lung and
everything like that right there like
all we should test we should we should
get a sample of his lung lining to see
if it spread like I'm like okay cool
what are you guys gonna do it we're
gonna take a sample your lung like I go
underneath the needle I come out a
[ __ ] breathing tube is in my lung doc
a date [ __ ] put aside I got like a
three-foot long tube to learn a little
box it's in my lung I was like what is
this like dark like what is this and
they're like well you know there's fluid
there I was like does not flew it in the
lung though that's fluid surrounding the
lung from the ascites is build up you
know going out that long another thing
was happening so what happened though
they cut the hole in the fluid leaked in
these good I love that they were just
like hanging out like almost like a
bunch of amateurs like something wrong
with your roof you like you know we
should try it's true that's right let's
rip up that plywood up and let's see if
that fits the link that's that's what it
sounds like they did the less Laura air
Carbonaro producer his father was
diagnosed with I think was a tumor or
something in this one particular doctor
only gave him a very short amount of
time
I believe was less than a year and so
they want to start getting up you know
more more opinions and what what they
found out was that that you know some of
these doctors love to make a case they
need somebody get help let him elevate
you know to get or maybe that but helps
them get you know work their way up the
ladder and you know and like you said
that you know you do till I'm with ya it
hasn't been great it was told me a year
and I was I been you've been given a
year to live I was like a human being
that got shook your foot said that yeah
do I played on my hold on a sec I play
the [ __ ] conversation I woke up from
a dilaudid sleep and had by helping your
foot shaking they told you over here
told me that they came in like six
strong there was the do Byron Jennings
there was Lauren Oliver's there uh
didn't look thin little asian girl who
was training underneath Byron Jennings
and in the lung people the thoracic
surgeons they were there and they were
all talking but the threads were more on
my side long story short do told me a
year and the way he told me I was like
not that's not that's not what's
glamping I don't think that's that's not
good and when did they tell you this
it's open an August sixth august six of
2015 they told me that and but here's
the thing i said cite cite your source
man he's like what do you mean I was
like in order to quote me something you
had to have had some study that you're
going off of right so tell me what
studied at your site you see that's
giving me like yeah what did you say
he's like I'll come back in the morning
I was like okay a some on a flagon of my
little tablet I'm like searching
everything I found this study he says an
average study the average age was people
were 65 to 75 years old who been smoking
and drinking been exposed to asbestos
immediately so they were so I was like
if a 65 year old fall down break their
hip I thought I'm break my I got a
better chance of recovery mm-hmm so I
was like yeah I'll do the chemo I'll do
chemo right dude didn't tell me anything
about what chemo is I didn't tell me any
decide affects nothing I walked in you
could throw a brick in my face right now
and I have more time to prepare for
what's happening what he did yeah and I
first of all how how can you come in
tell someone you got a year live and not
have the the the material to back it up
at that moment what a [ __ ]
yeah I don't like you're a little [ __ ]
go get your facts and then come back and
then I were like throwing poop numbers
do I I threatened so many of those
doctors like I fired one knows I go
don't come back in here cuz I remember
like I like my back had been killing me
I think it ended up being a bed sore cuz
I've been in the bed for so long even
though I got up every day 45 days even
though I got up every day what still ya
know yeah sounds like all right but I
thought it was like a slipped disc or
some like this I was like I asked for
x-ray the game an x-ray found a say hey
man I like to see the results of the x
ray he says why I said because I want to
see the results of the x ray yeah what
happened he's like oh well it wasn't a
slipped disc it was you know I was like
yeah school but I want to see the
results of the x ray he's like why have
to go upstairs and bring down a machine
and show you the results of x ray I'll
give a [ __ ] if you have to construct it
bring me down the [ __ ] results ran
out yeah sure dudes like I understand
you're getting mad I was like no you
haven't seen me get mad yet you need to
bring down x-ray so then so we got into
it and then do left do just walked out
just like passive aggressively stormed
out there and my homegirl was sitting
there and she's like did he just leave I
was like that niquette just let that
[ __ ] just left me he's a black guy no
but I say [ __ ] like a pronoun I don't
say like I'm Tina yeah um so I could so
he comes back he got a southern accent
three kids see ya again uh so he comes
back so I think he went upstairs the
word like they can you know they [ __ ]
congregate and like I just left his left
you know [ __ ] Jones his room and
they're like why and they're like he
told me to get his results I don't know
that it uh you can just leave a patient
so he came back oh they're all so he get
there all Ricky so he came back down
he's like I swim apologize I was like yo
get the [ __ ] out yup you come in again
I'll slam your head in between the
[ __ ] door handles like don't to get
the [ __ ] out man bring your boss bring
whoever's up by above you I don't want
to see you again don't come in here ever
again for anything for and he's also
told me the reason why i hated him so
much was because we were waiting to see
if the cancer it spread he
came in and told me on friday afternoon
Andy angels in there Nate Craig was
there he said cancer spread to your lung
here's the thing all the results were
him back in so he told me that on Friday
we didn't find out to another week later
they're like he he read you the wrong
results oh so it hadn't spread it hadn't
spread time is going he's making [ __ ] up
and all the tubes and stuff going and
you then mean unless all right hold on a
second I succeeded can we give the guy
little credit he predicted the future
well it did spread did you get spread
manifested negativity me show hidden on
the [ __ ] but hey whether you met a
fellow he was right well I'm just teeth
look she just left the [ __ ] outta jail
yeah no one's ever punched him in the
face I'll take one that's a team player
man my god jay-z team player guys don't
be fooled alright so let's talk about
how yeah that's a here yeah let's talk
about these chapters in your life that
lead us up to here cuz that is very it's
important it's important that with a
preface man yeah man preface the breath
right preface it so you're originally
from you said Seattle right in town baby
till six the other ones out he lights up
between the town to town never yet you
know like what Ben Affleck yeah for your
city should have been in see out the
town oh yeah not Charleston I like
Seattle sales growl of see I don't I
lazy oh yeah but it's a rip van winkle
city though what's that mean like you go
they're like let's say you and your wife
like let's get out early let's move to
Seattle you move there like with the
goal of two to three years tops you
blink your eyes there'll be five yeah
you have a Subaru Forester and Cesar
sounder and what I my conceding tickets
to the sounders you know kerman he
[ __ ] got a husky and you know your
babies is three and five and they're
taking Taekwondo like a bunny it's crazy
yeah you blink eyes and she's like that
time flies by cuz it's so cozy man yeah
so cozy sounds good to me too i'll be
doing a lot of [ __ ] salmon fishing
and crabbing up there too in between
those year kill guptill s it's just fun
I did I went to a very cold though what
was it like grown for growing up there
for you I mean
for me well you already said that your
dad was gone right bae bouncy-bouncy hey
you're raised by a single mom yeah so he
left at eight he wasn't really around
consisting but like he was going on a
treasure yeah yeah where'd he go I
didn't get as a jersey recorder I don't
know where to go in but you know ya he's
dead now so it's whatever cool yeah I
but here's the thing and I'm not trying
to be morbid or anything here but you
don't know what he died from no I dunno
what do you do cuz I when I when I got
out I tried to go track him yeah he died
from emphysema and pneumonia but he
smoked cigarettes like it like like John
Wayne but and pneumonia and pneumonia
huh probably smoking in the rain ya
ghali probably that pneumonia it
probably took him eventually got
pneumonia from the Amazon pneumonia I've
which I just recently had [ __ ] take
you out when you're in that when you're
in that kind of shape and that kind of
shave smoking like the senior citizen of
the negative side effects of Seattle man
yeah he was older he died like 86 oh
really he was math 78 when he had you
know he's like 60 son my mom was like 31
37 so he's a baller OIC passed away than
not when he left I got you right yeah
well they said 30 years old he's 30
years old on my mom's I think he was 61
and I say it's a ball but that's you
know what I mean um I did say but you
know what I did all right so he bounced
a date he's gonna make you lose
endorsements you feel is it our
endorsements are they left long time
yeah so he bounced like we grew up man
who grew up in the north damen and you
know like I kicked it in central
district and you know went to various
high schools usually you have with smart
kids were bored the system they did get
in trouble so were you a smart kid were
you good insight you can tell you can
tell me that might your dress by how
your talk you know like that you're
intelligent I know you're I know you're
book smart but was was did you do
because a lot of kids don't do well in
school because it's not challenging
enough to them they don't they're just
bored by it basically were you that kid
is that why you got in trouble yeah and
the system didn't make sense still
doesn't make sense to me as it doesn't
make any sense it's a
it's like it's like the formula for how
to succeed in school isn't designed for
everybody knows I'm summarization yeah
if you don't like if you don't do that
like the way to cheat the system is to
just do your homework participate in
class and in space to test that's right
that's it he participates in class he
listens he's a good student he passed
all his tests and they get it born after
a while you to shoot up to like 60 great
struggle with it so it was never boring
to me but you know that I'm sayin tip
someone like you and people like that I
can get that it makes sense to me that
that structure you're like we're going
now to this class for an hour and then
listen and I was lazy way like here's
the I suck at math though I come through
with words and people okay that's why
I'm good at this comedy [ __ ] words and
people but you stuck like algebraic
equation firmed up I I took philosophy
just so I could avoid doing any type of
man yeah like and then I was about to
graduate in there like yo you need to do
math 95 I was like so I went back to
like Community College was like I think
this is it really you're like you
couldn't do it at all I was like I
cheated I cheated every every does what
you didn't introduce you didn't teach
letters and numbers together [ __ ]
when I was in elementary school I can't
do it now as an adult I was like x
squared and I [ __ ] out of here man good
man copier on his own with his math and
now seventh grade and I just I look at
him I guys c'mon about that man I really
don't brush him now where I love math
shutter love it I love it or we got with
asic down would you get up to and man I
took senior advanced math in high school
that was the last year I was like I
demonstration [ __ ] like oh it took
chemistry to but that was that's that's
more science than math that's geometry
yesterday oh yeah I crushed I stituted
geometry the [ __ ] of you I crew your
nice guy knows rhombuses dagger in
theorem over here may explain she loved
it I thought I felt like it like I
always want I want to be a lawyer that's
what i thought i was gonna be out like a
courtroom lawyer like I just wanted to
debate and like you know and that's what
like proofs words like proving something
and you know using logic you know
anyway I really dug it I dug I love
numbers i still do so trouble led you
into what i mean [ __ ] like we used to
bang you know saying central to south
end like that those are the neighborhood
beefs seattle immediate city Seattle's
probably bout the same size Boston
Boston like what 2.2 miles long write me
need ya it's not big I didn't mediate
yeah you got you know you surrounding
South you know it is but it's like for
us is like central South in and it's
like maybe like three miles apart but
[ __ ] beefing yeah put just two gangs
you mean did not me not to do main gangs
like la here yeah ya do I shouldn't say
that cuz up and it was 18 about two men
give welcome to well I mean like this
Bloods and Crips beefing right there's
very in Seattle but yeah very set
because you gotta understand is that the
bloods crips in Seattle are the ones
that got ran about la yeah and they went
up to seattle i see that i watched lock
up a lot and I see that it's also the
same problem in Alaska to a lot of them
got ran out of here so you go up there
and started up there yeah man so who did
you bang with crit playboy Santana blood
supply boys in town block crib straight
up SBC you know what it is no i don't
what do you mean that that's like that
was your piracy that you guys would kick
it in or do you live there he said what
was that where you would like hang out
or was that did you live in that that
area that block I mean that's what I
kicked it yeah that's right state okay
my best friend he's a he's 74 / so 74
Hoover Crips yeah i mean you say like we
know what the hell your tongue oh what a
man this is that a night this is
wonderfully for knowledge my next
question right nobody questioned sorry
Larry next question I go man can be to
divulge the street tale what I mean
how'd you get into it like what I got
jumped in I mean like it is you do what
you choose to get jumped in well I mean
either daddy gonna get [ __ ] with while
I'm saying yeah um sensors are you uncle
[ __ ] with every day go ahead Junction if
you're gonna get your ass beat miles
well double yeah yeah jumped in part of
my mean you put in your work you fight
you know homie soon you know if
someone's in your hood didn't eight if
someone if someone from child it's
someone from Dorchester
is in Southie mm-hmm and they're beefing
those two neighborhoods are beefing and
they see him they go after him it's that
simple that same thing central South a
someone from the south end who's
prominently know is in the central he's
at a bar turnt up oh nothing tomorrow
get him boom just simple just for being
there just just just for having the
audacity to be in that without and to be
slipping so you know now if you're with
your family right but let me ask you is
it because that you're running drugs in
that part of the city and that's why
it's your part of the town or just like
nah man we just don't want you here I
mean because that's what mafi used to be
right it was like drugs and whatever
they'll run and then that's what I want
like that what gangs are doing price I
mean it still territories yeah in a
certain part you just can't go to your
certain parts to see how I still don't
go to yeah I damn sure won't be caught
in west seattle none your [ __ ] life
mmm Wesley autos like this dude I love
with ya what don't do that nah I don't
like what's the other because it's too
it's too [ __ ] there's too many ways
in not enough ways out I'm saying it's
like it's separated from the city it's
like Charleston that one bridge that
connects it right yeah you maybe even
give to it from enough from the back end
but that one bridge is the main way out
yeah the same way what is it with Wes
the other one brick one main bridge in
you can get to it from various little
highways I'm like that but the cops if
something if there's a chase they cut
off the main one and slow little trickle
until you just stuck there so we still
going to school while you were now I I
stopped banging I stop banging when I
got out the joint realistically when I
got when I gotta do I stop banging yeah
perfect let's talk about that right
great Dominic stop no wait when did you
go into jail I was 22 and hours i was in
school and I was hustling i'm selling
everything but in school you were
college housing kyle i was in college i
was doing everything but i was selling
everything but heroin and ecstasy
because ecstasy became manslaughter
charges after like 05 really really yeah
because that was me you remember I don't
you guys weren't bad boys to like when I
came out like every ecstasy was
everywhere if it's in mainstream movies
that means it's been going
on for a while yeah like that's why now
they're doing heroin even though it's
been sweeping the [ __ ] I saw her for
a while oh yeah so I so weird so I was
hustling I was making money I was going
to school there you know doing my money
and i met this girl i was [ __ ] around
you know and then long story short we
got no argument cops got called i went
to jail no contact order placed on that
right she felt remorseful couple weeks
later hits medley let's kick it i was
like nah you got the cops of all they
can't [ __ ] with you so she calls it so
she's like she's really angry i'm
ignoring them ignoring them ignoring
she's coming to my house trying to you
know trying to talk i'm like nine and
one day she called the cops from outside
of my house then she said you know she
snitched on me she's like yo he's doing
this he's hustling he's got pistols do
this together ok you got to check it out
they raided my spot they find everything
and then there's worn out for me so
there's a warrant out for me in fact
here's me I was going to court and
that's when they arrested me because I
was taking care of 10 for her yeah that
was the warrant that was out man that
checks he doubled up on you dark dark
like maybe i sat in the county for like
six months just saying it wasn't mine
it's not mine it's not mine because
everything you know I beat that case
because the department was in my name I
was subletting off craigslist they had
no fingerprints on the pistol they
couldn't find a person who did on the
apartment all that stuff you know and
saying like all it was his residence
like it's not mine I know there's
nothing I don't know any of this stuff I
don't except for this one I'm polishing
right here depresses should add I got a
partner did it didn't catch me and catch
me in here like they caught me at court
so they just raided my spartan every the
discovery packet the big came wit was
thickly like you're going down forty six
months i was like for the first time
ever being likely i'm going to joint for
forty six months [ __ ] out here i'll take
it to the box it that's the max I
calluses that's a cartwheel underneath
for yang to the Box man what's taking it
to the bomb take it to the jury yeah I
like that to them take that [ __ ] to the
box so you to the box so we tes I say
hey man forty six months is like
cartwheel underneath for years sounds
like and that's thing when he went
when they scented you dance in the gym
[ __ ] years it sends you much I'm here
like I do that more than 20 months you
look [ __ ] Jake here's 10 [ __ ] things
picture i see something is breaking
under pressure when they got this oh oh
wait a minute so you had to do a year
for because of this chick I wish you
know you guys still keep in touch no no
I am tartar years man that's probably
why they chat now with the can't none
are when dudes now when i got when i got
since dudes like Tommy's like you want
us to [ __ ] tighten up and my god
don't do that because it's automatically
come back to me yeah and they also
record all these phone conversations
please get off the [ __ ] phones in stacks
like I dog I man cuz I like I'll just
just let it be me I'll be on a little
bit so I remember sitting there man so I
guy sends I got cinders in my birthday
come on ditch it they're like like 13
months I say yes so it dropped from what
48 cuz they kept dropping the charges
cuz they didn't have any case yeah so
then when I was like you guys really
want to wait like I did like they would
come to me they were like here's the
deal I'm like that's not a deal that's a
dick and I'm not taking that so just
figure something out take it back so
there's public this public pretender was
in there doing that I was like yeah I'm
good I fired her got a good is the
shittiest reps the doctors to get public
defender firing him what up because I
thought it was gonna be up I was like
there's no case I was like we could hear
this easy but that what they do systems
a trap you know I'm saying to get you to
get you to sign a deal you're on
probation and put these outrageous
expectations on probation no one is
you're going to violate and every time
you violate your time for probation
stops and then when you get out it
starts again so it's a trap it's a cold
justice in the cold trap so I fired her
got a good lawyer boom 13 months I
signed it in blood so quick it was like
that's it from 4613 like please wait cuz
you knew that they had something
otherwise you would have kept going
right I knew that I violated no contact
order gotcha so I was like there's no
doubt about that and the way the
prosecutor came to me was like look you
take this deal where I'm going to go for
a extreme sentence
exception i call exceptional sentence
and try and go outside your sins it's in
range and try and get you more time and
I was like that didn't seem like it was
worth the risk so I was like I'll take
that deal gotcha so I took the did 13
got out got out Dave got out the day
before thanksgiving 2007 and then
started to adjust yeah man so what did
what did you do every day well walk us
through a day of jail wake up breakfast
for 15 hold on what was fifteen in the
morning yeah can I ask you to go through
your first day do you remember you gotta
remember it was every day have you
noticed that yeah that's why I'm saying
what is you are you scared are you
anxious are you you know is it what
what's going on you're drunk or high
going in from bought your tonight they
sent you oh so you did your turns up to
maximum levels you get a rest oh you go
i impress you when you agree hustle you
know you got the money so that's the
thing when they even a Glock me I was
like my bill I was like $20,000 ten
percent of that two thousand Darren in
my pocket I'll get a little [ __ ] bail
bondsman sign away to g po and right
when I was about to do it they're like
hey before we take your money I won't
let you know that they have seven other
charges pending at twenty thousand
dollars a piece o as I accept that's you
want a hunt what you want to how much I
was like now I'm good we'll sit we'll
sit here sudden you so rep starting the
food I remember I was so glad you havin
so crazy we're just I don't eat pork so
I was like I didn't have given with my
bologna sandwiches say they call me bird
man cuz all I ate was really the bird
the deceit they give me to give a seeds
so they give us like you know like and
so breakfast for 15 in the morning you
go back to sleep you rack out for
morning seven and nine what's that mean
Rach I means you get out yourself okay
and get out your cell what are you doing
with my team or not I simply watching TV
TV mmm you watch the TV is two teams on
its susi nothing you watching vh1 given
should I have watching vh1 music videos
the white boys haven't even have a trot
it's not black hey there watch the
country videos [ __ ] watch a rap video
bra that's it that's it and this is what
out like 11am EV some people walk in the
yard doing in yards and yards about this
big maybe higher higher roof about this
big block not the studio there yeah
there's like a hoop dear a pull-up bar
and a bench and our weight bench but a
bench how many people sharing all this
space yeah I mean each time if we if I
was an e unit each tank and each sell it
to people let's say maximum during the
summer when [ __ ] really [ __ ] up you
brag got 60 70 to sit in a room like
this while that ball take a shower and
homies and [ __ ] so it's just dispersed
between the space this is the yard
though this is like the full tank the
tank is it bigger yeah so you get out
you're watching TV and then what's next
they make you go back in there so back
back in nine o'clock maybe 930 they do
shift change they do outside lunches at
like 1030 lunch is thinner wait you
eating yourself you eating yourself get
a cell mate yeah yeah yeah how many you
have in that 13 months [ __ ] i watch one
to go and come out like he got out and
came back two times in your cell cell no
innocent in jail like he'd get out you
but I give out of your Burt anybody hear
me I'm out here [ __ ] came back July
seventh row I'm sitting here like Megan
I'm dying to get out of here you [ __ ]
coming back oh my god oh my god it was
it dives so seeing [ __ ] come back was
so stressful cuz it made you be like
what is going on out there yeah and he
rides something is just crack it and you
just like I so were you cool you sell
until they cool with you or for the most
part there's is there's a Samoan dude we
call it move services who's who had like
12 thing you always to do and I'd be
like I guess so ear to my god please can
you not do it in my bed who's he
couldn't help it substantive I'm gonna
get this thing down cuz at this point
cuz thing is when you come in and you
start you're in a top buck great
then as you get seniority or the [ __ ]
gets out you a cigar can I moved to the
bottom bunk all right cool you move to
the bottom but then you know starts at
but I was there for so long I was that
then I got moved to trustee after like
four or five months what's that trustees
like you get to be outside yourself and
you're like a tank worker r us was gonna
say like you in charge of some of the
guys they're doing working like that
yeah and that was dope and then they
move that usually reserved for guys that
have been in there for 25 years and ship
over people were good you know because
there's a waitlist you sign for the wait
list and you earn it we're [ __ ] go to
the joint [ __ ] go to the gym late are
you I'm rolling up your work I'm one
step closer to take worker then if you
get it to jail if you're like a trustee
of the jail dogs chili get all day
you're all days he's working so
what'swhat's lights out 99 pm-9 p.m. we
usually lights out lights how they do 10
or 11 11 but you're back in yourself
your back so you reading your book you
know they only allowed three books they
do random rage they find stuff you right
back you lose your whole yard time you
go crazy in the sale you sit there like
having 13 books sometimes I have more
than three books have more food once I
got rack back I have more seeds i
suppose that they're like burn man with
the seeds game and burn man you're
grounded now plan I was there just real
this is real [ __ ] man like I love the
birdseed I love the seeds they had like
good honey roasted seeds what were they
sunflower seeds no not on David receipts
like like flavored tea Tonka and then
like you obviously get money but a
different in prison I get hop gets up
right now is your seeds i mean you know
cuz they they're keeping coffee you know
saying that's a company bush runs bush
owns keep you coffee they got in this in
a system how about that I was like
thursday like you trustee like so
obviously how about that obviously you
can't just live off jail right so you
get money in the book so then you bite
your soups you bite your soups if you
playing bones you gamble with soups
mm-hmm get to join your gamble smokes
you don't say but [ __ ] got currency in
there right so
and they say they see into a big store
whoa I mean something could walk back
two bags santa claus [ __ ] soups and
cookies in and then honey buns and help
them they earn swiss rolls and [ __ ] man
like sometime sometime because you just
have a lady a family out there and they
were just all mad dog and then you just
gamble with all that you I mean
sometimes if I you eat some time like
when we rack out for lunch lunch at
twelve dan like we'd make spread or a
night time we make spread so someone you
get a chili you get you get like a chili
soup and I got a chicken soup and then
you gotta be so we put that [ __ ]
together you know I'm saying mash that
up should've let it sit man at dice up
some uh some turkey sausage some cheese
or cheddars you know a little cheesy
beef jerky sticks in the die set up in
there man [ __ ] mush it all together
man that [ __ ] was gourmet even say three
you guys which like maker that week
sometime we all come together everybody
on their [ __ ] together everyone dog we
put it we made a big aspirin the trash
dog chili here everybody a real rap you
real rap like we'd all put together like
then we make pies you take all the
cookies so you say with the cookies from
your lunch right to get like good ideas
you mash up to for the crust then we get
a fruit we get a fruit get dice up the
Apple so [ __ ] dicing up apples with
sports okay that's a word you dicing it
up and in there boom oh man and what
would you cook it microwave it oh you
have microwaves yeah we're not savages
I'm have one cookies with the app this
is all right so how did they cuz i watch
lock up well how they do all this crazy
[ __ ] and it just blows me away did you
guys have a holic drink or something
else did yeah we were jus did you get
them snuck in did anybody get them from
the outside to come in like a beer here
and there or what that we have pruno
bruno one time fermented fruit but how
about at work just save a fruit put it
in a trash bag but that it [ __ ] you up
tell me when you when you just detox
yeah yeah after you been after you've
been you know down eight nine months for
me then you get a little some some with
a little kick grape juice will [ __ ] you
up you'd be like that
hurts I remember super no one tells like
welt nah it was appointment I was so I
was so like condition after being like
that when I got out me and my boys had a
big ass party for me at the club wait
can I can just bring it back one second
I want to know go ahead i'm sorry i'll
shut up no no I want to know about the
night before you got out you know what I
mean like the day the night your you
know you are okay you get you have a
date right first of all yeah in it every
day I'll write down so we don't forget
to talk about the party outside every
day you wouldn't you want you hit like
two weeks that's what everyone's
counting down for you all right before
you are they trying to [ __ ] some [ __ ]
is trying to fight you to make it used a
longer she's so so sometimes I like a
man say they were like yo hey I got I
got I got I got 13 days in the wake up
wake up grout so they don't count that
day so it's like all 12 days wake up ten
days six days and wake up and finally
three so then wake up like me tomorrow
birds out all right oh man spread pies
everything man I got stay out late but
they roll you up extra early day out
late where the hell you go I mean just
till 10 with the trustee tape okay
mm-hmm so then we do now man [ __ ] car
man it was for the night before I'm i
was giving away [ __ ] [ __ ] like you'll
make I get you get your baby powder caca
check out on me ocean I'm itch lotion
mean they will take the lotion now a min
to me but I remember my girls like I'm
fire-sale your song made up giving out
you you'll get a couch you can you get a
car you get a car yeah for every ball
that old are you so much for having one
for everybody made a big ass spread I
remember cuz like [ __ ] like yo order
big bird just out there order big store
this week Bert or the big store this
week so we can all eat when you getting
when you leave him and we're big ass
spread that's like nah man cuz you get
the money back on your books oh you did
it out sounds like I I'm just I just I
just chill but I blew through all my
savings my hustle savings paying a
lawyer yeah and paying for apartment
that I wasn't staying in sit-downs like
I so I hit the streets of $77 oh geez
after sitting on 10 yeah I the streets
of $77 so I was like magnet my girl that
i'll hook me up with a job who picture
did anyone pick you up that day yeah my
mom my girl at the time my cousin Sean
they came got me but here's thing I were
glasses but I got in a fight in my class
is broke so it was like a gradual
process gotta fight first the arm broke
off in the fight and then it fell and
then like the frame the joint part right
here mm-hmm where did my back in here me
stuff I had the joint part right here
broke so then like it's loose so like I
have to keep holding it together while
you're fighting would not just like a
seat I am finally finally with it I got
so good velma from scooby-doo over here
I got so irritated man i was like my
[ __ ] broke the glasses and was just
going through the going through blind so
the first thing we did when I got out
we've got out temperatures at first I
thought for the first thing because it
was so early we went to denny's and
everyone's out temperatures then he's
had two moons over my hammy I had to be
the best [ __ ] night chocolate chip
pancakes orange creamsicle shake man and
hash browns and scrambled eggs with
cheese I remember sitting there like oh
my god because it's such small portions
in the joints right so when I got a big
players like offices if I can heat all
this I can't eat all this [ __ ] food
I'm pushing her way back like the black
he's gonna do with all those cookies
then we went to doctors now that was the
neighborhood yo's night before and night
I got out Nick dad I started working a
foot luck Wow the dead like you know but
that's great not only see great good for
full they hired a god out of prison for
one day I for damn that interview
process buddy but like not it was my
girls friends about her so I was staying
in Tacoma so like I was staying in
Springfield yeah and work it oh I
minutes to me you gotta be the only guy
I've ever got a job at like a
respectable place the day after you got
out of that was the thing that was a
deal man did I'd have a jury
oh I have a dress they were going to
release me too and I had to have a job
and so otherwise there's something if
you're if you're homeless if you're you
know you know address and I don't like a
stay in their path when it's supposed to
be out because you get a third offer
good time so you had a job set up yeah I
bet you were an employee of foot locker
while you were technically still in jail
yeah I have no stripes Matt you man my
life's work good for you too I had it
all set up I'd all set up I wouldn't
stay with my girl in tacoma at the time
and then did you like it in jail did I
like it it's a great place to visit Joe
and live there yeah were you comfortable
there were you ever worried ever a
hundred percent comfortable there nine
on this initiatives like man I trip and
I do my five like whoa I you know that's
five yeah 60 months you just okay we're
just not throwing that away for what
yeah I'm good fam I guess I see some
crazy [ __ ] I Snicket squat so much
weight his [ __ ] rich what wait what
are you do oh blues ever been squatting
my dogs prior like maybe 445 each
morning Scott went down put us in a
scene his 12 got tired of getting
bullied he took away and just while do
was [ __ ] curling just asked him in
the head why was I was doing girls yeah
he's curling and just you just took it
like a freeway boom we lost weight so I
was it no more weights done yeah just
that was there I think they took him out
of the California system now all
together cuz guys are just getting too
[ __ ] big like why do you need to be
in there but getting bigger than the
guards I mean it's the saying what about
Aunt Jean it's about routine yeah you
said I remember one time i watched it
was a lock-up and i want to say Rikers
Island there's it's dude who is yoked
and he doesn't lift the weight but he
sits in his cell he'll get on his hands
and like in the corner do handstands and
just bang them out all day and they come
in and they're like watch this and they
put a regular set of handcuffs on him he
just goes snap pops him right off so
they have to put him in full-on shackles
to move him around cuz he can he can
snap regular cuffs behind his back like
it's no big deal on he's just looks like
steroids but it's all pure
no the crossfit craze the guy was on
that's just a joint routine for free
white people man that's all it is that's
holiday no I bet I walk in the gym I
what I walked by crossfit today the one
of main street next to downtown
independent I walked in and there's just
like a bar and like a big tractor tire
and a rope and I'm like we were doing
this [ __ ] and I draw it like this is all
stuff like [ __ ] doing just bar just
bar work out yeah yeah so like cats in
the bars like always working i'm on the
bargain okay cool do this you don't
sound like you don't need to be a
certified gym trainer but you do this
that gets that part get the biceps the
further you go out work in your back and
push ups you do narrow you're getting
the [ __ ] that's when you get in the
starting to get in the [ __ ] the
valley and I'm saying you do further why
that's when you get in the cup size
units when you get the [ __ ] full
circle right there boom posted so
sometime you're doing like this you do
10 10 10 all the way out 10 10 10 on way
back in I mean you don't need such
[ __ ] gonna figure out get diesel bro
yeah so um you had said earlier you
something about dominos was that where a
fight over dominoes was that in jail is
[ __ ] do named Shadow deed is shadowed a
shot it on man hold on step out of the
shadow and bring your brother heavy man
he's in the shower that was smooth doing
I was good I'm [ __ ] words from the
rain just being thing are now the shadow
demons they usually little here's a
little little bass head from from
downtown from the south and put [ __ ]
kept cheating and bouncing he'd talk
[ __ ] but he was cool i set mine or my
neighbor red to red was doing fed time
and state time right he went down for
some other [ __ ] so he was looking at
double time he was just trying to get it
ran concurrently not not consecutively
so we're like our hearts up long story
short stinking shot her d keep doing
this i said man do this he's like Nikki
you ain't go was he doing he kept
palming the [ __ ] balls yeah tell me
what ha I know what I mean I know you're
like long he's going like this but the
[ __ ] trying to sneak the bone
underneath the table called Domino Oh
like I say
you're gonna find it down there
eventually aren't you I'm just like dark
because we have to shuffle the balls and
then with just three or four players we
all got seven someone short where's
about all I know is right there stick it
kept doing it and we're gambling with
it's like my dad to know that shoulda
came bro you won't catch this fade I
promise you man he's a big e ain't gonna
do now sigh I shadow dark [ __ ] get
killed for less bro like you'll get yo
get tighten up fast man like you ain't
gonna do [ __ ] Barry I'm so sick of you
that are you a [ __ ] and like hey call
me a [ __ ] one more time I come across
this table in seinen it's alright cool
it was a so we keep playing and he
starts twisting this hairy thing first
pitch who threw [ __ ] balls i stopped
cross to penn técnicas College Avenue A
Thousand top of a nigga's head bro I was
on top of the [ __ ] here top five I've
never reacted that fast my life like NFL
Combine time like that's [ __ ] yeah
like I was over the table and on his
helmet before you can even blink can I
hurt her i was there i was way now's
like he don't set you gonna try eat
gonna try you he don't try you dog he
going to but he was quiet so I was like
I was like don't even sit back don't you
say cuz he won't say through [ __ ] so we
playing phone she'll get you better but
make this [ __ ] not okay cool I do it
you gonna say some city birds [ __ ] so
do you get what you get for that would
it with your what's your trouble for
that inside I lost my rack over the rest
of the day that's it for one day I mean
they weren't I was our humble say that's
worth it then now they were gonna throw
in a hole I mean I'm lucky just fight
know like this as fighter because I
never had any interaction no infraction
before [ __ ] new like they everyone saw
a building up you know everyone saw cuz
it [ __ ] kept saying [ __ ] it kept saying
and guards are right there here and
everything right down to the [ __ ]
they're looking alike but they couldn't
pull me off and I was plastinated yeah
they let you go a little bit yeah let's
get it I heard him call you [ __ ] I
remember a they called medical center
code blue for when the guards come in
and they let that go for about 45
seconds man yeah 45 seconds just me just
working at [ __ ] in there like medical
side to go blue go blue cards coming
bird bird what's going on we [ __ ] this
guy mailbox oh man was crazy is fun
though you and I have something in
common i witnessed uh that the aftermath
of a Domino's fighting Community College
I've told this long time ago but I went
to catonsville Community College which
is in Baltimore County and in the
cafeteria area they used to be a lot you
know used to be a lot of card playing in
between classes right mama knows
whatever Pete's no past the time and one
day somebody cheated and they called him
out on it and the dude was so upset
about it he picked up a chair and he hit
the guy over the head with it and ended
up cracking his skull and they had that
they had to land a helicopter to fly
this dude out like that's how severe guy
and the next day there were signs on all
the poles in the cafeteria said no game
or card playing like that that was the
end of that [ __ ] yeah i mean that's
terrifying to me because that's that's a
charge yeah yeah that's attempted murder
yeah exactly that's too that's the
biggest thing with me like I don't fight
no more like I'm just I get hot I flash
I might like slap somebody else like
trying I do damage like these so even so
you get out yeah and there was a party
you were saying I interrupted that sorry
I get out many of a big ass party for
birds home and Q's home and was good so
hey desert is agree to big ass fired it
was where this club in Pioneer Square my
forgiveness the Auto Club shut down and
open back up with new names but it was
like guys like do not deviate some [ __ ]
some [ __ ] go to name was [ __ ] bottle
we bottle service ever like I'm gonna
just do trying to give me lay this is
family and friends this is just your
friends just my this is the hood just
friends you know they're like pirates
out it was good we bout to take
everybody to get your dick wet but teach
you is as I has been a little bit and
I'm ready what was happening so we got a
little party man we go to club they gets
cold anxiety like it's too much too many
people too much movement that the strobe
lights here I'd
never break down man I didn't really oh
yeah I lost myself this is day one out
they want the evening of day one don't
read yeah yeah you did a 10 free dhum I
read my girls like we go i was like Sean
going and going out with the homies man
sitting like whatever not sure if I'll
be back I'm back and so like and I
remember next day was thanksgiving and
we were with her family and then the day
after that was a was why i started work
so it was moaning time to turn up but I
freaked out I couldn't handle it was too
much stimulation because I was like yo
jist girls like hey what's up me when I
like that now I'm good man just called
me i told my wares like oh man this is
before Uber's you just [ __ ] so just like
yeah I'm good I'm gonna call like nah
man like we'll get some sort of drug
down like I'm good man I just gotta get
out of here right now I can't take all
this so I animals going outside just
chillin like looking up at the night sky
Z been like yeah man used it all that
time you didn't snitch you just nice
crazy what you gonna do now kill you
2020 no no no you 20 30 into still its
young I was like what you going to nail
me oh no you don't figure something out
and I'm thinking this myself co comes
out so I was talking to me it's call you
what's happening you're the boy Varner
everyone's here for you why you hired
Mike just not feeling it then she's we
end up talking hitting it off and it's
like well I'll take you home I was like
I was like say white just I can't take
you out that good dick meal perfect go
for her so then when was it that comedy
came in after all that like then were
you where you see start wearing a
footlocker i went to the joint cuz I
didn't know what's gonna happen house
like I don't know I was gonna make it
out cuz I'd never been locked up before
mm-hmm so I was like I don't know how to
make it out so I did an open mic before
I never lock before it's what I know
it's just the toilet big mistake were
there any open mics in the in the clink
reach the freestyle did you used to
freestyle eyeliner end isn't agree on
rap to this day career
that is prison career I said yeah I put
I put hosing your blocks like the holes
in your socks and things like that's a
cuz you gotta sit here big turtle the
hall Oh God thinks is going hard after
that I renders country doing in the
country co name my name on Gilliam kill
him he always did chu always did two
other than their know what he's still
chillin today yellow bring your skull
bandits and your Hawking bring the
captain man I he everything about doing
the French Foreign Legion when I got
what he's like yo they let you start
over fresh and France they give you
money but you abandoned on your
citizenship I was like oh you have to
bet ya to be a French Foreign Legion I
was like my own sound too bad man i got
too much gone to any way i might do that
but i didn't do that but Cynthia and
then in the comedy I got in the comedy
man i started doing comedy I went to
school did a couple open mics I did a
couple Mike's man i did it i went to a
couple comedy competitions i remember we
did this one in Yakima but how old are
you at this point I think I'm 25 but see
this is the thing that's amazing to me
is that you're coming out of jail but
you have the perspective and you you're
so well-spoken I mean how's that even
how do you even like um you don't
picture someone cannot come in on jail
and then just get in a comedy and people
like oh what's up man and just being you
know in it you know I'm saying you feel
like this like a transition period it
feels like for you just like I did my
time I'm done this is who I am now that
does exactly what it was because like I
didn't want to go back yeah like there's
some dudes like that like they go to
jail they don't mind how's that I can
never I think you go to jail is probably
blessing oh yeah because if you didn't
you would have kept going a something
you would have you had tripped up
somewhere so I have known that I even
look at this cancer is a blessing yeah
you know my god ain't no way I would
ever follow Chris Rock this soon in my
career you know wherever would have got
to feature for bill bird is soon in my
career yeah yeah I'm saying like
everything's happened for a reason like
these kids are sucked at first like a
lot you know
when did you fall rock uh lack last week
week before last how was that shower was
watching a [ __ ] wat watch growing up it
was great i was watching for backstage
like this dough rock still god i guess
the throne isn't as bacon as we thought
yeah they're like I'm like I right we'll
go right and they're like hey you feel
like going out for my god damn right I
feel like going up yeah but when they're
like after rock I'm like okay you want
me to follow right so I go out there
some likes I I was tweeting out arenas
like you you belong here your best
you'll keep doing this like you here for
a reason here for a reason I show time I
get on stage throw three Jets all jokes
hit our that I do one it grazes then I
was like would you guys expect you don't
sound like you just watch Chris Rock for
free down the best Africa so you thought
I was going he referred out the park
that heat is that what you thought I was
gonna come out do some ricky do it is it
not man come on man like come on you're
not even paying attention you thinking
about breakfast you think about lunch
tomorrow like you're not paying
attention my subway joke it is it and
then everyone's like okay okay okay so i
just did 20 reset it yeah it's funny I
did 20 look for you [ __ ] like a homo
good man yeah I would expect it i mean i
wouldn't expect you not to you know i
mean yeah i mean she was crazy now you
watch nagoo you grew up like them that
nigga's vs black people bit and no sex
in the champagne room are the bits that
made me want to do come yeah then in
verse black people music i had thoughts
like that i should say those things yeah
so crazy to a lot of people forget like
when you're following a beast like that
you gotta do everything you can just to
reset the wrong gotta distract I mean
you gotta like it use trickery so that
was great that you addressed it and then
got everyone to move on because
otherwise there they would they would
just hold you this expectation the guy
that's like one of the greatest ever I
mean it also worked at like I mean I
always address whatever's in the room
you know Diane like if someone says
something I could rip off that I could
go off that real easy but it was like
the first through tougher
like there were Chris jabs I was like oh
how much I'm about to go for a knockout
wait till i get this and the other one
Gray's I like oh they want to dock me
how they go kill me with crickets they'd
go kill me what crickets down I was like
nah but everything I did I did 20 and
then like yeah I told judge to tell
chris i was like you tell them tell them
thanks for opening from you yeah totally
but Chris Rock could just kill like
non-stop yeah man he's like Nathan I can
conversate you just kill you're just
like like his jerk came i did a question
answer with him I was like yo stop
please stop like stop stop killing so
hard like you were going to make it
difficult to follow mmm please I was
company I got into debt of doing comedy
competitions in college I saw Seattle
I'll see all sad it's got a good got a
really good comedy scene yeah then I got
serious with it about 2010 when six
maybe 2,000 I get serious I was like I
want to do this full time I did like
full I did like maybe like a year and a
half and then I moved out here that's
great I was like I'm ready to go pro
yeah I was like I'm ready to go pro like
all I knew was Rory was moving down here
I Duncan Trussell number and then and
this is when you realize we moved down
here their phone numbers mean nothing
because I hit up trestles like yo man
I'm here man what's up and ready to
grind his I am at the improv were you at
I was like at a mic with the [ __ ]
media well I took like order to him
problem not a headline earnings what are
you doing yeah cook it up he's like all
men stay in echo park or like get out of
your house upset cuz I thought I mean
you know you all have a delusions where
we come here how's it gonna be right for
a show get discovered yet it's great
yeah then you really like it's just like
doing that dishwasher two weeks you
figure out if you really want to do it
or not for four years I did test [ __ ]
yeah man a thousand sets in 2013 that I
would get every festival possible day
nothing no bridgetown no [ __ ] nothing
2014 when I got festival yeah then I was
like it's always like that you when
you're ready for it they ready you know
it's
like few that they're like they're ready
for that person when they're right you
know what I mean no I'm told know a lot
oh yeah we all on the rag man I told no
6 times X week but you guys pay your
bills off tisha doesn't send you all I
want to do yeah but now I'm hot now man
yeah well I'm hot so let me ask you this
then because I mean this is a legit
question I think especially as a
comedian we were talking before we
started you've got this GoFundMe right
right and are you ready for your hour
are you ready to do your our tell you
hell yeah I'm ready to do my hour I mean
this is some of my turn and burn
material so quickly but it's like for me
the now it's about piecing together you
know I'm saying like now it's like not
just going through the book like okay
well these are all jokes right I could
do 3 i'm gonna do go to 30 in Ventura
after this hey I'm saying I'm just doing
ok Cruz but now is about piecing
together ok white people brunch yelpers
my intestine to do it now is about peace
in the air so it's smooth because you
look at it dis ain't just time for me to
do this is like me this is like me
having a rare opportunity to transcend
the hierarchy of what comedy huh no late
night said no colleges no company
central half hour no [ __ ] acting in a
show no our just just died you transcend
all those to get to the hour and now
it's I'm ready for it I'm ready to do it
well I mean it's a different time to you
know there's so many different ways that
you can get the things you know what I
mean how does use cancer yeah all you do
is you can smell a man
price we pay for success so wait they
told you in the ultimate price they told
me we'd actually be trying to drop it in
august sixth what do you mean I'm
nothing special in august six which
would be the air anniversary I like the
one year they told you hat and be like
I'm alive [ __ ] what's happening
yeah what if you die in the seventh man
this the special still gets marketed
great remember business leverage all
right if I die in the Sun just made me
think of this too what have you done do
you have something set up with them who
does it go to is go to your mom yeah it
goes to my mom it goes my mom my niece
my nephew okay I got niece nephew 11 13
oh that's nice yeah you know that every
everything's everything set up me
because when you're young like I'm 31 so
like when you get faced with your
mortality it's like everything I thought
about that was like optional before
marriage kids you should like that all
that is now like brought hella close see
you're like yeah I want to get married
like with anybody marry me I don't want
to die alone like i don't know i don't
mind i I just don't wanna die alone I
don't want you to be reaching out for
the clock radio and fall off the bit you
know saying like I don't want that so
it's terrifying so let me well we're
while we're there have you been have you
thought about it Barbara what like what
since they told you had a year how often
do you think about like the idea of
dying do you keep it in checked you put
in the back your head I mean I know to
be positive you have to put it I don't
know I mean I don't know but you don't
put it to you like this dog it's like
for me I'd say i don't i don't think
about it constantly but it creeps up
yeah you know i'm saying it's like when
you raise your kids you don't want to
think about all the bad stuff not
raising oh man ya feel me but sometimes
up and i'm right now as a dad I'm
thinking about your mom but mama yeah
your mom's losing all on few passionless
I'm a one who like really told me to
keep fighting like there were times like
during the heavy kima where I was like
man [ __ ] mom i think i'm good i lived
a good life i did a lot of [ __ ] I think
I'm good she's like good life you were
in jail for 13 months she's like nah man
she's like I don't she's like knows no
mom went steer some time
like that so you gotta fight house like
I I mean cuz the chemos [ __ ] die
like now my emotions are [ __ ] up I am
done [ __ ] up emotionally because now
anything anything with cancer or death
makes me weep yeah like I watched Creed
it was like oh I think you're gonna say
like you're ordering a coffee and they
mess up it like put your soy milk you
just lose it I mean sometimes I lose
this year like riders deco bad customer
service Deadpool Deadpool made me weep
other honor got cancer and is everywhere
the name iWatch Creed Deadpool all these
[ __ ] getting cancer it's a
movie that's how common it is now oh
yeah Oh cancers I mean unfortunately it
is it's come it is it's it's I mean I
feel like it's like a cold you hear
people these days it's like somebody's
got a cold it's like holy [ __ ]
everybody's got [ __ ] cancer I got a
few bits on it though they're funny I
mean I'm not gonna talk about in it
during the special hey don't burn don't
oh you're not doing the special no
you're not gonna talk about your health
at all no I like that idea it's not a
cancer specialist is special yeah his
name is a cancer specific and I had if I
had another one in the can like TIG did
then yeah it would make a cancer
specialist as special this is my I want
to Patrice I want elephant I want to
Kurt Metzger I wanted white boys oh yeah
and you gotta you gotta understand take
new she's gonna live we have no idea
what's gonna happen we don't we don't
I'm no teasing that supposed to battle
guess it's not that funny but I thought
was pretty fun no it wasn't but we don't
know yeah I'm weeping out Crab Shack
errs Crab Shack grab hackers rough you
uh I mean at the end of day my life is
good man like that guy I've heard you
joke about it I mean before we started
what was what did you say about you feel
the pressure about all the people make
it dawn the money always muhfuckas
donated money if I live too long I feel
like I gotta die I gotta [ __ ] right here
like jam Ziggy drop us any more success
haven't got three albums like a father
fire camp for years has been
[ __ ] look at Magic Johnson accommodate
seriously he's stronger he's still
hoping he better not be off it man you
seem to those push-ups he's going 10 in
Oh way why and then back in Nam is for
like there's that pressure because as I
[ __ ] [ __ ] is happy like I'm I feel
like I'm I feel like the people are
behind me so like I feel like it's
genuine support along it is genuine
support and you're putting that price
don't put that pressure on yourself
there's everybody out there it's just
root for you they mean it's gonna be
good you know no one's gonna know I'm
not worried about the special I'm where
I mean ups afterwards like I this has to
set me up so I can eat for a year you
feel me like this like I have to be
doing full-time comedy like this like
now you're going back to barista like I
have to be ready to do that otherwise
like my mom's always like just just pace
yourself I'm like she don't get it yeah
you got to be warm when you're going
into the air you can't be starting to
stretch and saying like I gotta be I'm
going to road to atlanta boston to
[ __ ] get warm I've had all the stage
time I can handle out here you know yeah
i've done an hour in Seattle I'm going
down Atlanta get the southeast version
northeast version back to the town back
to LA you know amen because it's got to
be ready masters got beat up as a lot of
people I'm you always got your naysayers
a lot of people rooting balat of people
like see what you think really gonna
talk man I mean this this I mean I'm not
saying that I just think there's a level
of like it's such a weird not weird but
like a an interesting situation that
came together it's so it's it's special
man it really is special it was amazing
to me the biggest thing was like last
comedians in this town all comedians do
is wish like other people sky they see
other people get stuff and you get gels
and envious and hear all these people
coming together to support you you know
it's it's a it's unique man it's it's
[ __ ] great I just feel like I put it
out dude oh yeah I'm gonna without that
support I trying you know reach out but
all it's also a testament to who you are
to people what I'm saying right that's
when you realize what kind of friend
what what kind of person you r is when
friends like this step up for you then
you know you
a good person I mean that's always shady
DS you know but chez dede but I won't
respect those naysayers are the same
mother [ __ ] are trying to fight you
get you in to stay in to put in jail
longer they're the same on the outside
they just all it's just not a bunch of
fences around us when I [ __ ] those
people I'm not tripping out those
mundane [ __ ] man I'm good I'm hot right
now like I like it that's thing you got
it I got a float on it I got a vibe from
it like i'm a hot right now like i
didn't know i was hot until i started
getting some of the calls i've been
getting was like what you guys heard
about it mm-hmm I know cuz they were did
like you're in split side I was like I
don't read that you not getting ready
time like that's world star hip up for
white people don't need like no you're
out you're on GQ I was like okay the
kids yeah okay your boy got up with the
q GQ you boys here and behind the scenes
Judd Apatow doing what he's doing yo
shout out Judd Apatow visas and like I
appreciate everything that man is done
and I just joke when I was like I just
need five speaking lines man so I could
just get sag insurance bro like that's
all I need yeah I get sag insurance I'm
good I'm good I go to any back there was
a concerns and let me just cast me
mm-hmm I thought where I get a credit
he's like just slowly let me get your
doctor yeah yeah it's a healthy but no
real talk he's been he's been dope man
like I just like the support I really
feel like I put it out there and for it
to come back the way it did was just
like oh [ __ ] I can be with sharing
stories and stuff ideas like it's not I
didn't do nothin [ __ ] in the hopes that
would pay me back yes I did it genuinely
because I love people I love comedy when
you locked up in the joint yeah I'm
saying when you grow up broke yeah I'm
saying like they're like when you grow
up what I grew up this is a blessing i'm
in la doing comedy i'm a popular
comedian in a scene that's one of the
best in the world I got no complaints is
hey it's 83 days in november out of jail
is a big [ __ ] place to be let a
little you don't let that's what I'm
saying you remember like I'm here yeah
like I remember your store making your
pandora station I remember seeing your
late-night set like I remember all these
things and like man I'm here so for me
it's like
goddamn right I'm happy to be at a
[ __ ] Mike right now yeah you
feel me I could be dead I could be in
jail I could be married with kids I
could be doing all that [ __ ] I'm here
telling jokes and I'm supposed to be
upset at my life cuz i got cancer nadar
I'm good I'm good respected man says I
mean you got you gotta keep it like that
there's someone who loved your problem
like when I was in hospital 45 days
people who had to like like so many
visitors were coming that people were
like yo you gotta wait I'm saying his
rooms full he can't have any people I
remember there are people in the
hospital like the nurses were standing
room only man he all goes down it's
something we deal with it over Mike in
the hospital did you really yeah we rent
out we had a little side room and a
little amp just just dope that's tight
but it was like the love there was so
overpower it was over bears like man I
was like this is great yeah like the
fact people came to visit I knew it was
hard for me because I looked bad well
that's what I wanted to say you know I
know you said you don't want to die
alone and i hope i hope you live a
healthy long life not too long as we put
some money why i want you here we did
winter we did throw some money and we'd
like that bag of you make it over 65 /
sweat if I mean that in the Kickstarter
caveat where is it that's not to pay
back 35 I'm in debt but what this is is
love and you are not alone and that and
that's what I wanted to say like you
know don't forget it your second album
should if you if you do end up living a
long healthy life should be like oops
that's what your second album should we
go oh you met I wish I could tell you
guys the title of the special I'll tell
you off yeah tell us all oh but it's
dope still alive yeah that's better than
it okay mommy is pretty good still alive
that'll be album two or three album for
should be still for ain't dead yet okay
yeah sound like too short titles don't
like short album titles are old master p
covers so totally still balling hmm well
this is I tell you what this has been a
lot of fun man I and I'm glad you came
on i'm glad you're you're I'm glad
you're here i am i'm glad you're brave
not talk about this got to me yeah you
do have to
good for you thank you guys for ever wow
man kidding me oh yes an honor um whole
bunch of legally gonna tell his wife
when he go yeah he said take it to the
box oh babe you better watch my mom take
it to the box eh let's take a picture
for you everything good specials hey
that's a good faith let's take a picture
for the grandbaby take a right big grin
when she tomogram why don't you one more
time please tell everyone where they can
find you on social media tell them
specifically where they can go to that
go phone me if you like to donate money
sucker pay rent go to the GoFundMe
that's a GoFundMe com backslash Kwame
don't play that and then if you would
like to donate to the special the
Kickstarter you can do that I actually
don't know the kickstart but because if
you could just google Quincy Jones
Kickstarter yeah that's my credit right
now good day whenever well thank you for
being here thank you very first time
I've ever meant that in every way
possible oh thank you God and dose check
them out live if you're gonna be on the
road i'm sure people can fall on twitter
they're gonna be able to see you not I
my twitter account locked but second
burger we do burgers okay i know i'm
coming in lab site not on our website
atlanta i just got hot so now i got to
get all this right here but uh atlanta
boston and i'm running the hour in LA
next monday right on my mark seven so I
meltdown if you guys won't kind of 9pm
to I got Rory opener for me awesome dude
awesome look he got work I'm great to
have you man as always Jay Larson calm
be calm Jay Larson comedy on all social
media Ryan Sickler on Twitter Instagram
and Facebook where you guys better
follow me back in the real dough Bob
listen I try keep my following down to a
minimum you know I mean I don't know how
long even gonna be there I was going
that was a duplex I've had that locked
and loaded all's I know a good look I
said we jump up after this we'll talk to
y'all next tues deep